visit expressvpn.com and get three extra
months of expressvpn for free
[Applause]
you know in new york like rikers island
it costs around 200 000 a year
to keep somebody locked up now
per events per person
yeah you know what the four seasons cost
in new york city but ritz carlton
about six seven hundred dollars a night
and then some people will say well in
other parts of the country may not be as
expensive okay let's take a different
number let's take a number like
fifty thousand dollars a year you say
okay well in
parts of the midwest or here or there
the cost is is
you know is less for various different
reasons we don't have to get into
the cost of locking okay 50 so that's
the cost you can put them in the holiday
inn for that right that breaks down to
about 140
a night there was a story that a new
hampshire corrections officer
said to me while i was on the trail when
i was running
he said we should pay people to stay out
of jail because
we are putting so much on them when
they're behind bars and this is some
worked in the system
and just saw uh saw where the money was
going every day
and he said this to me like the trail
like even someone who's part of the
system was like hey we should we should
be sent to the holiday inn is what he
was
suggesting because uh you know like
we're doing it wrong
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to yang
speaks the founder of lava media
one of the founding board members of the
innocence project
and the host of the wrongful conviction
podcast which speaks for itself
mr jason flum welcome jason to yang
speaks
thank you thank you i am uh honored
actually to be here and i don't say that
lightly i i am a big fan of your work
and uh super excited to speak with you
today and uh
yeah let's go man i'm psyched i'm a fan
of your work a super fan i feel like
you're one of the reasons why
the vast majority of americans are
waking up to the reality of how messed
up our criminal justice system
is uh and you just joined the board of
the frederick douglass project
that is helping to make that case you've
been
in this uh i want to say for
decades uh you started uh going down
this path before it was cool
really you're one of the people that
have woken up so many of us
how did you get involved with this work
back in the 90s oh
well thanks for asking i um it was very
random or
maybe not maybe just serendipity i guess
you could say but as it happens this
particular day
i was uh getting in a taxi and there was
a newsstand and i wanted something to
read in the cab and
the times were sold out which was my
paper and is my paper of choice
i live in new york and uh the new york
daily news was there so i grabbed that
and i was obviously meant to grab it
because there was a story
the headline was something like uh
ferraro bid for
cocaine kid parole or something like
that right so it's geraldine ferraro
they were talking about
of course was the first woman ever
nominated to be vice president
for by a major political party uh when
walter mondell was running
and the story was about a kid named
steven lennon who was serving 15 years
to life for a non-violent first offense
cocaine possession charge in a maximum
security prison in new york state
and i know yeah exactly right i see your
face and i'm sure people at home are
like no
shut up you're stupid what are you
talking about that doesn't make sense so
i'll just repeat it because it doesn't
make sense but it's true
15 years to life for non-violent first
offense cocaine possession charge in new
york state it was a rockefeller drug
laws
so i read this story and i everything
i thought everything was out the window
my sense of fairness and equity and
and justice were all just tipped upside
down and shaken out and i was like
i have to do something this is insane i
had had my own substance abuse problems
as a kid
and um you know i'm not a religious guy
but i was just like there but for the
grace of god go
i or so many people i know and
so make a long story short i ended up
getting
uh the only criminal defense lawyer i
knew and i knew him from my day job
running a record company right
or working at a record company because
two artists had signed skid row and
stone double pilots were clients of this
guy
bob colina and they would seem like they
were getting arrested twice a week in
those days so
i had him on speed dial so i called bob
i asked him if he could help he said it
was hopeless it was a rockefeller drug
law there's nothing he could do but he
took the case pro bono because i was a
good client
and six months later we ended up in a
courtroom in malone new york
and um the judge banged the gavel down
and
and sent this kid home um and it was
the greatest feeling i can't describe it
i mean i was sitting there holding mrs
lennon's hand when her son was freed
and um i was like now that's
i want more of that i want that feeling
and i'm going to do
everything i can to repeat that as often
as i can for as long as i live
and what year was that that was 93
andrew so
um it's a long time ago and
um you know and that led me to joining
the board of i read about
families against mandatory minimums in
rolling stone magazine at that time
and so i joined their board that was the
first organization
who i joined up with wonderful
organizations still doing fantastic work
as
as you know but for people who aren't
aware famm.org check it out
amazing um and then soon after that i
saw something on television about a
case that the innocence project had
recently won where they
had prevented this gentleman from
getting executed and
proven that he was in fact actually
innocent and he was freed and i thought
that
i didn't even know about that i was like
it never occurred to me
because this is 93 94 whatever it was
it wasn't in the media like this it is
now you know like wrongful convictions
weren't a thing people talked about it
you know i
i thought somebody's guilty they must be
guilty but uh
little did i know so
you helped free this uh this kid uh
he was 16 years old or like uh how old
was he that like uh
mr lennon he was 32 when i learned of
his case he had already been in prison
for over eight years at that time
and um oh gosh yeah so he was the same
age as i was
so you have your big shot lawyer
essentially be like yo do this thing and
he's like all right i'll do this thing
because
uh you you you're like a good client and
our practice makes a lot of money so
we'll do this as a feel good thing
uh so how the heck does he get in there
and six months later the judge hangs the
gavel
and um and sets um
this inmate free like like is he a
wonder lawyer or or was it just this
no the fact that someone was chasing it
i don't think he's not alive anymore
um but he's he was a wonderful guy
i don't know if he's a wonder lawyer he
wasn't a famous lawyer or anything like
that i think he
you know maybe he was looking for a pro
bono case around that time
um and you know the crazy thing there's
so many crazy things with this
particular case but it's far from unique
so stephen lennon had been in his car
with a friend and they stopped on the
side of the road to
urinate and i guess an officer had seen
him doing that and
then you know to approach the car search
the car found
4.2 ounces of cocaine under the seat now
it's not a small amount
but it's also he's not el chapo right so
um
he both kids denied uh you know
possession of it and so both of them
were charged with the full amount
because that's how the law works
and in new york state the rockefeller
drug laws mandated that possession
of anything over four ounces was an a1
felony so it's the same as murder
and doesn't get higher than a1 and
so the and the problem is whoever's in
the car
the whole thing will it'll split it it
belongs to you all of it belongs to you
and so both kids were went to trial and
they
you know they were tried and convicted
and um
and mrs lennon had been trying to get
governor cuomo which was mario cuomo
and andrew cuomo's father to grant
clemency
to mr linden to her son
and had letters written from the
sentencing judge and the warden and
geraldine ferraro and all these people
and this was
just a homemaker from rome new york but
she wanted her son home
you know mother's love and uh so it was
it was an extraordinary situation
because she had just been turned down
and that's why the story was in the
newspaper that i happened to read but
so bob came up with an angle the other
kid had
had nothing to do with it in fact and
when after stephen was convicted he
wrote letters saying listen it was not
the other kid
he had nothing to do with it i was just
giving him a ride it was mine
uh and they said too late you know we're
not concerned with that anymore so the
other kid
eventually was allowed to plead down to
an a2
um meaning to the possession of two to
four ounces
so bob went in with the legal um
uh approach i guess uh
angle where he said hey you can't charge
the two kids differently for the same
crime
um and if the other kid was allowed to
plead down to an a2 my client should be
able to do the same thing
and i didn't think we had a snowball's
chance in hell i didn't know anything
about the law back then
but you know i knew that the judge was
an old guy with white hair he looked
like ted foresight if anybody remembers
that actor
and i thought this looks like a
conservative guy no way are we winning
this case but he banged that gavel down
andrew and said the motion is granted
and then bob came running over and i was
like what happened and he goes we won
i was like we what he's like we won i
was like
okay i don't know if i can curse out
here but i was like get the f out of
here
you can curse on yang speaks
i was like get the [ __ ] out of here
that's incredible and so um
so yeah the uh actually funny i i was
just going through my drawers i have a
picture of stephen and his uh and his
mother right right over there
a few feet away from me um so that's
that's stephen lennon right there no his
mom
uh yeah and that's his mom that's his
mom shirley right next to him and then
uh this woman this amazing woman is
julie stewart who founded
families against mandatory minimums um
so yeah it was a wonderful experience
and it was transformative for me and
you've had that experience now
uh many times and you said like i want
that experience again
how many people have you helped
facilitate
uh the freedom of uh from a wrongful
condition
well interestingly enough his wasn't a
wrongful conviction stephen was in fact
guilty but he was he was a mandatory
sentencing case
um and those are uh i've been involved
in a lot of those
um and and i don't know i've lost track
of how many people i've
helped and it also depends on you know
many cases i'm
just a small part of the of the you know
the team
team yeah right um and with the podcast
you know uh of wrongful conviction we're
shining a light on on some of these
cases and
we've been very very blessed to have
played a uh
a little part in helping a few people
have been on the podcast actually get
the attention that they needed and
um you know i've been told by people
involved that
it had some little percentage to do with
their
ultimately winning their freedom even if
it's one percent i'm thrilled
um so i don't know how many you know
i've worked on
on clemencies at the presidential and
gubernatorial levels
um i've worked on uh cases with
you know connecting pro bono lawyers and
probably some are listening now that
might want to get involved i hope
um with people who you know who need
help and of course then serving in my
role
as a board member at the innocence
project and these other organizations
you know there's countless uh people who
have been freed but those
i i have you know i'm really in the
background
to say you know i mean the lawyers are
the ones doing the work
and i want to take nothing away from
that um i'm
you know i'm very i get it man you can't
be like i did this but it's like i
touched or helped out with
it sounds like dozens hundreds of cases
yeah i mean yeah hundreds some of them
have had the chance to be you know more
personally
connected to um and some of those
people are people like i know and you
know i've also got a very large
sort of family i guess you could call it
of exonerees and
others who i've who i've gotten to know
through the work
even after they got out even cases i had
nothing to do with
[Music]
of the things that have changed my life
through yang speaks
i'd have to say the unagi scooter is
either
number one or tied for number one
it's this freaking tesla of electric
scooters
where you get it and you zip around um
it it feels like a magic carpet my kids
are so envious because they're not big
enough to ride it yet
i don't know if this says something
about my parenting but uh now
the older one i do stick on uh the
scooter in front of me
and then i whizz around on it but it
makes you feel like you're in the future
it's environmentally friendly you just
plug it in if you live in a city it will
transport you where you want to go
uh you know without having to to
struggle with um
public transportation it's beautiful
it's slake
everyone looks at it and it's like what
is that that's the unagi scooter for you
i can't speak highly enough about it uh
we got a second one
and then now when someone visits me like
the two of us go around
like we're in this really uh futuristic
scooter gang
where we just like whizz around and uh
generally just
have a blast we even went out at night
because these things have these
headlights that really make you seem
like a ufo
um you know it's like uh i don't know if
you've done that zach have you done that
i've gone at night um in new york
it is awesome to ride because it's
faster than the bikes generally speaking
um or the regular the slow city bikes um
and faster than runners
uh i i love it it's not that heavy
either it's like it's like 25 pounds or
so
uh i think 26 pounds the exact weight
but it looks good folds up it's
beautiful
um you can basically have like 20 miles
of range
um and they actually this is fun because
it's actually just one award cnet gave
it best all-around electric scooter and
then it won its first place
for the best electric scooter by uh
tom's guide so it's not just us
starting to rave about this thing it's
real yes and right now for a limited
time you can get 150
off for the holidays this is the lowest
price they will have
for the next year so check them out now
you will be glad
you will be grateful this if this is a
real game changer
you can get yours today at
unagiscooters.com that's
u n a g i scooters scooters.com
[Music]
[Applause]
it is tough trying to stay healthy
during this pandemic
and one thing that helps me stay healthy
and a lot of other people stay healthy
right now
is freshly what the heck is freshly they
send you a fresh cooked meal
it's delicious it's healthy you don't
have to do a whole heck of a lot at all
it's like you know when you're in those
grocery stores and you see that
like rotisserie chicken meal in the in
the container and you're like ooh
and you know you just like get that
thing and you bring it home and eat it
up and
it's good it's like that it's
essentially those meals that get sent to
you
i know you're like wow that sounds
pretty fantastic and you're not the only
one who thinks so
because one and a half million satisfied
freshly users do the exact same thing
they skip the shopping prepping cooking
and cleaning they just focus on the
eating
and the healthy living so for a limited
time freshly is offering
our listeners forty dollars off their
first two orders at freshly.com
yang that's freshly.com yang feed your
body right
just get some freaking freshly in there
tons of people are using this
join in skip the shopping prepping
cooking cleanup freshly.com
yang i love this thing i'm ordering here
in jacksonville too it's great
it seems to me that you're a person who
stands not just for
common sense solutions to modern day
problems
but also for a basic fundamental
fairness and equity amongst
people regardless of their background
anyone hearing that story about these
two people who were thrown in jail
and one of them you know might have just
been a passenger in a car and like you
know might not even have known that
uh there was cocana this year like what
the heck you know they're listening to
this and just thinking
like what uh what an inhuman way to
treat someone
really like i'm i'm for humanity jason
and i think folks instinctively know
that at least then now they know
that our criminal justice system has
been
dehumanizing folks in different ways for
a long time
yes i'm glad you said it that way we we
have uh you know
along with the wrongful conviction
podcast on our feed we have two other
wonderful shows one is called
uh false confessions wrongful conviction
false confessions another one's called
wrongful conviction junk science
and on the first episode of the first
season of junk science
we had a guy named chris fabricant who
is the um uh
strategic litigation director at the
innocence project
and he he said the
justice system which we call it a legal
system and i can't really call it a
justice system
there's so little justice in it but he
said it's an effective
killing machine of mostly poor people
of color um and you know
it's really true and i'm paraphrasing
but that's basically what he said
but the fact is the system is so bloated
and broken
and you know i've focused a lot on what
i call the second punishment which is
and by that i mean what the way we treat
people the way we stigmatize
and discriminate against people after
they've served time in the system
innocent or guilty
which is exactly backwards of how other
many other civilized countries do it and
exactly
the opposite of how we should do it we
should be providing a ramp
and a lift for people coming out so that
they can get back on their feet so they
can help their families they can pay
taxes so they can
integrate back into society in a way
that is you know fair and and
helpful to everyone and and you know
it is interesting too i think that
um and of course we do the opposite we
we we
discriminate against them in every
conceivable way
um consciously and subconsciously and
you know in practically
and you know in all in all kinds of ways
but um it's
it's incredible that that you know the
amount of money that it costs
us as a society and i think this is one
of the reasons why conservatives and
and liberals and people in the middle
are aligned on this issue
almost at the exclusion of every other
one right and it's hard to think of any
issues where there is any sort of
agreement whether it's the environment
or
this or healthcare bipartisan support
around this in a way that's uh
somewhat distinct i agree yes
and it's you know a libertarian uh a
true libertarian is going to believe in
small government and is going to believe
that we should not be doing things the
way we're doing them
um and anybody i think with um you know
with a strong sense of common sense or
humanity
is going to agree with most of the
things
that you and i are talking about today i
think because you know we have a system
where
and we'll get to the economics in a
minute but
when you consider the fact that we have
2.2 2.3 million people in in
prison and while we're sitting here
right now in behind bars
in these tiny cells um forgetting
covered but being subjected to
extreme deprivation and hardships
deprived of sunlight this deprived of of
of their families
deprived of the ability to work
contribute to the community go to church
deprived of exercise deprived of love
deprived of everything and it's this
over
incarceration that has
taken the place of slavery or as a
continuation of slavery
as people who read the new jim crow
would know or or watched 13th
and it doesn't have to be this way and
it never was this way it never was this
way in america before and it never was
this way in any other country before
and i know that number is is hard to
conceptualize 2.3 million
and it's hard to think about the 4.5
million people that are under the
control of the system because of parole
and probation
but you can think of the numbers like
this
we lock people up black people up in
america
at six times the rate of south africa
during apartheid per capita
now every time i say that i take a step
back and i go go
slam you sound like an idiot go research
that again because that doesn't make
any sense but it's true you can research
it as many times as you want it's still
going to be true
we're we lock people up at five times
the rate of the rest of the western
world per capita 14 times the rate of
japan
and at what cost right i mean forget the
human toll for a minute forget the fact
that
every day about approximately 12 people
die in our jails and prisons in america
not too many from natural causes
you know we see the george floyds we see
the things that are happening in the
streets but we don't see the people who
are dying or being killed inside the
jails and prisons in america and it's
all too common
and then you get under the hood and you
look at the costs
right just the pure economics of it you
know
in new york like rikers island
it costs around two hundred thousand
dollars a year
to keep somebody locked up now
per events per person
yeah you know what the four seasons cost
in new york city the ritz carlton
about six seven hundred dollars a night
you know except maybe in the super high
season
you know maybe during fashion week or if
the groundies are here i'm sure it's
cheap
i'm sure it's gonna be cheaper now maybe
maybe we could put someone up at the
at the four seasons for the same uh same
cost
and then some people will say well in
other parts of the country it may not be
as expensive okay let's take a different
number let's take a number like
50 000 a year you say okay well in
parts of the midwest or here or there
the cost is is
you know is less for various different
reasons we don't have to get into
the cost of locking okay 50 so that's
the cost you can put them in the holiday
inn for that right that breaks down to
about 140
a night there was a story that a new
hampshire corrections officer
said to me um while i was on the trail
when i was running
he said we should pay people to stay out
of jail because
we are putting so much on them when
they're behind bars
and this is something worked in the
system and just saw uh
saw where the money was going every day
and he said this to me
like the trail like even someone who's
part of the system was like hey we
should we should be sent to the holiday
inn
is what he was it was suggesting because
uh you know like
we're doing it wrong and did you tell
him hey by the way i'm the guy that's
trying to do that i'm trying to give
people a thousand bucks a month
yeah i i i think he did know that at
that point
you're like uh yeah i'm doing that boss
yeah
i'm that guy doing my best i used to
tell the story jason i said look
if someone comes out of jail and they
were bringing a thousand bucks a month
with them and that person would have
like a much better chance of
reintegrating
uh and being put in situations where
they wouldn't feel like they
ever want to you know go anywhere near
prison again and
have a better chance of you know
avoiding that
so i you know that but the cost is
something you're right that unifies
people because when people hear the
numbers they're like no way
yeah that's our tax dollars being paid
and i mean the the
you know the the numbers you can break
it down any way you want and it's just
it's all insane but you know we have
basically one out of every four people
in prison in the world is a prison in
america
but we only have like 4.4 percent of the
world's population
so that i mean it's interesting because
senator jim webb
who was a republican well he was a
democrat when he was a senator but he
was the defense secretary under ronald
reagan so he's no
no lefty uh liberal guy right but he
studied our prison system extensively
and he studied the japanese prisons
extensively he spent a lot of time over
there um
[Music]
and he found that they had at that time
about 70 000 people in prison
in japan pretty big country japan um you
know
somewhere between a third and half the
size of america in terms of population
right
um and so he was looking at it and
saying how come
the crime rates are the same or similar
there doesn't seem to be any
real benefit to society of locking
people up the way we do and so he said
the conclusion that i came to
was that there's only two possible ways
to look at this
either we have the worst people in the
world
and they need to be treated this much
more harshly than everybody else or
we're doing it wrong it's like you know
the conclusion to the obvious conclusion
is we all have the worst people in the
world we just treat them worse than we
treat other people in the world
and the problem is it starts the moment
you're arrested
that's when we turn you beca and i think
it's because of the bloat of the system
right you have so many
11 million people go in and out of jail
every year in america right 11 million
what kind of crazy i know it's too big
of a number for most people to
conceptualize
but it's easy with it happens to you and
the problem is
jail is a barbaric place i mean it is
um i think you know victor hugo would be
horrified by what he would see if he saw
our jails and i think as
in general people think of jail as a
more benign word than prison prison
sounds like maximum security prison
and it's terrible i'm not minimizing
that but
jails in this country are generally
worse
more dangerous never cleaned no
recreation
mixing of people who are not haven't
been tried
with people who are already found guilty
gang members with people who are picked
up from
minor you know minor things jumping a
turn style or god knows what
and as as such it's an extremely
dangerous place and
they're powder kegs for for disease not
just disease but for
people are many in many jails people are
crammed into cells multiple people in
one cell
um you know it's it's a really
terrible scenario and that's partially
because our bail system is so out of
step with the rest of the world it's
clear that we're just criminalizing
poverty
it's like you you ran on a foul of a
particular um
rule and you can't pay the fine or you
you know the
or you can't uh
like afford the the penalties uh that
there have been
uh a lot of instances where folks have
been
not tried but are just put in jail and
then are just in jail interminably
because
uh that like they can't afford to uh
to pay a fine or make bail or do
something that that would give them
their freedom
and that seems wrong to just about
anyone who looks at it and it's like
wait a minute this person has not been
trying convicted and they're just
behind bars indefinitely and definitely
yeah years and years and years i mean
cases
have gone on as long as 10 years without
a trial and and
you know khalif browder rest in peace
was in jail in rikers island for three
years in new york for allegedly stealing
a backpack no weapons no guns no
no nothing no drugs no priors he just
was a kid
and he didn't do it but that's even out
the window his bill was 2500
and he couldn't post it and that's why
now i think that these
bail funds are playing a really
important role and i'm very proud to
have been a part of the original bail
fund which was the freedom fund in the
bronx
which was designed to prevent tragedies
like khalif router from happening
at all
[Music]
[Applause]
here at yang speaks we're all about
fighting for your data for our data
we have a data dividend project trying
to make it so that
the interest of the people get
represented at in state houses
around the country we won prop 24 which
is
making data rights a real thing in
california thank you to everyone who
supported
prop 24 but in the meantime if you're
not in california
and you want to have your data be
anonymous truly anonymous
we recommend that you use expressvpn
vpn's a virtual private network an
expressvpn
is rated number one by cnet and wired
all these big companies use it
it's like a portal to the internet
anonymously
through some server someplace else you
can do whatever you want you can get
content from other countries
uh we we major whatever and i'm kidding
i don't know why i thought of france
just then so stop handing over your
personal data to the big tech companies
that frankly do monitor your activity
sometimes they even sell it
protect yourself with a vpn that we
trust here at yank speed
to stay safe online visit expressvpn.com
yang
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s vpn
yang to get three extra months for free
go to expressvpn.com
yang to learn more
you know i i would like if it start with
you andrew i want to read just a little
a paragraph
because i think this really crystallizes
the situation
in in a way that i i'm not eloquent
enough to do
so this is by alec cara katsanas this is
an excerpt from
a book called usual cruelty which i
think everyone should uh
you know take a chance to read if you if
you get a chance it's um
it's a profound uh
searing indictment of our system but it
also
is a look underneath uh
places that they people don't typically
look and alec is a guy he's the founder
of the civil rights corps
um and he has been suing cities and
counties around the country
and winning um including places like
houston
on the legal premise that money bail is
a violation of the 6th and the 14th
amendments right it's not
you can't call it equal protection or
due process when a poor guy
and a wealthy guy or a guy with money
both get picked up for the same crime on
the same day but one goes home and one
stays in jail
that's it it makes a mockery of those
two amendments to the constitution
and so this is the first uh this is the
opening of the book
which i'm going to read you now on
january 26 2014
charnel mitchell was sitting on her
couch with her one-year-old daughter on
her lap and her four-year-old son to her
side
armed government agents entered her home
put her in metal restraints took her
from her children
and brought her to the montgomery city
jail jail staff told charnel that she
owed the city money for old traffic
tickets
the city had privatized the collection
of her debts to a for-profit
probation company which had sought a
warrant for her arrest
i happened to be sitting in the
courtroom on the morning that charnell
was brought to court along with dozens
of other people
who had been jailed because they owed
the city money the judge demanded
charnel pay
or stay in jail if she could not pay she
would be kept in a cage until she
sat out her debts at fifty dollars per
day or at seventy dollars per day if she
agreed to clean the courthouse bathrooms
and the feces blood and mucus from the
jail walls
an hour later in a windowless cell
charnel told me that a jail guard had
given her a pencil
and she showed me the crumpled court
document on the back of which she had
calculated how many more weeks of forced
labor separated her from her children
that day she became my first client as a
civil rights lawyer
so that's where our tax dollars are
going
is to send a team of people
to rip this woman away from her two
children because she
owed money for old traffic tickets um
you know it happens all the damn time
this is not a unique case by any stretch
there are so many there are you know
so many people the numbers are insane
you know it's almost 500 000 people in
jail right now awaiting trial in america
well
80 percent of them are awaiting trials
when they've been convicted but so call
it 400 000 is a big number
people like charnel who didn't who have
no haven't haven't committed a crime she
had traffic tickets
what's going on here there's a
sense that's borne out by a case like
charnels
by some of the brushes that each of us
has
uh with the legal systems that if you
wind up on the wrong side of the system
then uh no one's gonna listen to you no
one's gonna care
you know and it's very very different if
you have some financial resources if you
can afford a lawyer if you can call a
lawyer if you can
um if you can make bail or
pay a fine and if you're on the wrong
side of this and you don't have
resources then
uh your invisible unheard
uh just completely
trodden upon uh and then the and
we've been almost conditioned not to
listen because
it's and this is one reason i'm so
grateful to you and the folks that you
work with
on these cases that you've been
screaming
look these are human beings this system
is
unduly punitive and unjust and a
terrible use of
taxpayer money and public resources uh
and now i feel like the momentum around
this set of issues is higher than it's
ever been
uh you know and i feel like you're an
interesting
um uh example where you were awoken by
this article you said that you had some
substance abuse problems when you were
um young or challenges did you ever run
it run into the law during that time
uh you know i'm glad you asked i
i distinctly remember now i had so much
hair back then andrew like my hair is
still pretty thick
but when i was a kid i grew it uh to
absurd lengths
and it was so thick in the summer that i
i really couldn't see where i was going
it was a
just almost like a hair helmet and um
and one time i bumped into a cop while i
was smoking a joint
um and i remember him saying put that
[ __ ] out
and i was like oh yeah sorry officer and
i threw it on the ground and
rubbed it out and kept moving um that
wasn't the only time i had an
interaction with
um with police officers but
that one i think there's a lot in that
story you know i mean i
i definitely feel
uh i feel certain that had i been
in a different zip code with a different
colored skin that interaction would have
ended very differently and there would
have been many others because
i was always you know smoking weed you
know
and um i was always around people who
were doing other things and it was like
there's no question that i would have
had a
very i would have had an awful
experience had i
been you know somewhere other than where
i was and i think that's one of the
reasons why i can't leave this alone
because it doesn't it doesn't work for
me that
other kids um who grew up
and didn't do anything you know
terrible didn't do anything differently
and i mean
you know and by the way i believe that
drugs should be criminalized and taxed
um but they you know they were illegal
back then that cop could have arrested
me
and he didn't because i was on a you
know i was on a nice street in a nice
neighborhood and my skin was white
and that's you know i'm grateful i don't
want to be arrested but i don't want
anybody else to be arrested for that
either
and so yeah you know you see this two
days and every time something tragic
happens
to a person of color uh possibly caught
on videotape
um there's all of this clamoring around
like well
uh here's what this person did wrong or
this person was no saint
and i just hear this i'm just like are
you kidding me it's like you know like
there you know that if a different
person in a different zip code with a
different background did a similar
behavior like the person is alive and
well
you know it like that like that's
that stuff um there's like a very
natural human tendency i try and be
forgiving of
where people are kind of looking for the
rationale or the justice sometimes in
very very
blatantly unjust and brutal and inhuman
behaviors and it feels like this is a
case where
we've set up these institutions or
organs
and they've gotten away from us they've
like gone to the extreme
uh in for a lot of the same reasons why
a lot of things go wrong in american
life is that there's money involved
uh so of the things that i ran on and
one thing is to get rid of
for-profit prisons entirely because that
just is a banana's concept it's like oh
let me see if i can make money off of
the incarceration it's like your
incentives
are so shitty in that case it's like oh
will i be spending more money on
trying to rehabilitate uh my
prisoners and like treat them well or am
i gonna treat them like [ __ ]
and i actually profit more if they come
back like you know and
like if i get any money left over i get
to pay myself i mean
that that is just a perverse situation
that we
have allowed to happen in the united
states of america
[Music]
so pumped that we have a new sponsor
here i want to talk to you guys about
hawthorne which we found and it is i've
never been excited to take a shower and
use a body wash before that's kind of
what i feel so here's
what happens so a lot of our ads we do
like these tailored uh
we love quizzes apparently so you take
this quiz online and it's random from
like
what type hey what what is your
priorities when it comes to deodorant do
you want antiperspirant do you
sweat a lot do you just want it for
smell that sort of thing what are your
priorities for a body wash do you want
to smell good you want to scrub
dirt like whatever your preferences are
and that goes from lotion to
hand soap to face soap to all these
different
uh conditioner all these things your
hair your body your skin all these
things
and then they send you a custom version
of um
all of these whatever one you pick and
honestly i love it
i have been trying all of their products
even i'm like a stickler on
a certain types of deodorant i even like
their deodorant um so if you want to
upgrade your self-care routine
hellothern is like this fun community
way to get extremely high quality
products
tailored just for you just very cool
it is fun how now there are more and
more
tailored personal products for guys you
know i grew up in a time when it was
just like one thing
speed stick yeah irish spring
bar soap oh yeah that was the good stuff
man
like clean as a whistle um but now
you have like legit self self-care
that's tailored to you
because not every guy is alike you know
we actually have different
um skin different hair different
grooming needs and the rest of it
pretty much anything's access to do in
this area you should definitely do have
you seen zach
he's a very very well groomed gentleman
um
you know uh comparing around him
[Laughter]
right up on the trail he was always
shaming us with his
hair and his face all right his facial
hair
i hate this add now just kidding i do i
really do like hawthorne
go to hawthorne.com and use promo code
yang to get 10 off your first purchase
that's h a w t h o r n e
dot co promo code yang hawthorne dot co
promo code yang
[Music]
the drug laws you were talking about
with uh steve lennon's story
the rockefeller drug laws i think it
sounds like you believe that the drug
laws are a huge source of this problem
as well
absolutely i think that the war on drugs
is the most disastrous
uh failed social policy since slavery
and in many ways is actually just a
continuation of slavery
um it's it's cost trillions of dollars
by now it hasn't had
any positive impact on anything drug use
hasn't gone down
it doesn't there's no correlation that
any social scientist can find between
the drug war and and drug abuse or drug
use or whatever
and it's just it's just a it's a money
machine
i mean funded by taxpayers um you know
interdiction is a joke
it's impossible to stop it and people do
drugs they've always done drugs cavemen
did drugs right cavemen did peyote
little children spin in a circle until
they get dizzy because they like the
feeling of being a little bit out of
control right
it's just so i think you know i'm on the
board of the drug policy alliance
and you know we espouse a philosophy
called harm reduction
and harm reduction basically means first
you accept that drugs always happen it
always will be a part of society and
then you start sitting down and figuring
out how do we minimize the amount of
damage that drugs will do to the society
it's not by destabilizing foreign
governments
it's not by defoliating forests it's not
by locking people up
we're still we're still still arresting
over half a million people a year for
pot in america
there's still people serving life in
prison in america
for pot it's legal everybody's making
money
it's nuts so yeah i mean the and the
drug war
you touched on this before andrew you're
absolutely right it's always
used as the pretext and the excuse right
oh well we thought we smelled weed in
the car
or they looked like uh or we're gonna go
bust down brianna taylor's you know
we're gonna
go to do a raid like we're looking for
osama bin laden because we heard there
was some drugs in the house
there's probably drugs in your house
there's probably drugs in everybody's
house i don't know i mean i don't do
drugs
personally but you know most people do
and most people
and she didn't by the way but it's
irrelevant if she did or didn't
one of my campaign pledges was that i
was going to pardon
uh everyone who was in jail for a
non-violent marijuana-related offense
and then i was going to high-five on
their way out of jail
and i was joking i would do it on april
20th
i would have done it any day but you
know i just thought that that was like a
you know like a funny image of me
high-fiving folks on their way out of
jail
um and
[Laughter]
an asian president he's just pardoned a
bunch of non-violent drug related
vendors and one of the
jokes i told is like those are the folks
we should be pardoning not these like
well-connected
rich weirdos
we should be parting folks who just
shouldn't be in jail in the first place
and at this point
marijuana is legal in a whole lot of the
country and we have people
who are behind bars for doing things
that people are doing openly
you know in colorado and other parts of
the country at this point doesn't make
any sense
uh but so that to me was like a
no-brainer that
most americans would agree with and then
you can go up the line
i i was for decriminalizing opiates um
uh and for safe consumption nights and
other things especially that plague
because that has become widespread and
it was essentially government
facilitated
i mean the government just turned a
blind eye to the threat of opiates
uh in in the form of purdue pharma and
the rest of it
and and then we criminalize it on top of
it it's like you go you show up and be
like hey
sorry you're all addicted while we
turned a blind eye to this stuff it's
like let's throw you in jail
like you know i mean like like that
stuff didn't make any sense
to me i talked to folks who
swear by psychedelics as a treatment
for uh post-traumatic stress disorder uh
and other conditions that many military
vet that struggle with and
that that made me a believer in the fact
that we should be
uh letting folks experiment um so that
the the
uh criminalization of a lot of these
substances has led to
this overgrown system that has enabled
uh all sorts of brutal behaviors
uh and the examples you you cite are
dead on
yeah i mean look the war on drugs we
know now has been confirmed but i think
it's haldeman right
who was nixon's aide uh who said and she
was you know
i guess starting to look at his own
mortality uh several years ago he said
look nixon didn't
care about drugs he didn't want a war on
drugs he wanted a war on black people
and hippies
but he couldn't call it that so we
decided to call it a war on drugs
at the time no one in america cared
about drugs it wasn't on the top like 50
issues that
that people cared about um and so they
had to figure out a way to make people
care about it so they came up with this
marketing thing the war on drugs
and then because police departments also
in the way i understand it originally
didn't care about drugs they didn't want
to go arresting low-level people for
stuff
like that so they created these
incentives right where they would give
these
bonuses and extra equipment and military
equipment and all this other stuff and
um they created quotas for these um
local
uh police departments to to make these
drug arrests in order to incentivize
them to do something that they didn't
want to do i think they were
preferred and probably a lot of them
would still prefer to be out there
solving
you know violent crimes and helping to
prevent violent crimes as opposed to
you know just wasting taxpayer money and
inflicting unspeakable cruelty on people
who may look something like the children
you know their own teenagers at home or
whatever but but that's not the way it
is
and it's it's got to go back in the
other direction because
it's just freaking wrong it's always
going to be wrong
and then when you look at other
countries that have done it differently
the results that they've had are
profound portugal being probably the
best example of that where they
decriminalized all drugs in 2000
and nothing bad happened nothing you
know
shockingly right nothing bad happened
overdoses went down
like you know there are a lot of
positive results uh
i i saw that data too and became a
believer
or at least a huge believer in the fact
that you'd have to really
exert yourself to justify why it would
not also reduce
overdoses would reduce consumption here
in the states
it's again it's like that uh the
question is like are people just
worse than other people other people's
people
like that's like like you have to kind
of go there to justify a lot of what
we're doing
you know i did a presentation for the
democratic policy committee in the
senate
many years ago and i said you know i
talked about the fact that you know
what how is society have benefited if i
had been arrested instead of gone to
rehab which i did right
i ended up building a company employing
dozens of people
paying lots of taxes creating some good
stuff
some good music helped me to create some
good music that people liked it had a
lot of enjoyment
uh uh listening to um
you know it's like i didn't need and and
these other people don't need to be
arrested they need well most of them
don't need anything they need to be left
alone
right and the few that actually have a
substance abuse problem and my problem
wasn't pot
um at the end you know those people need
to uh
you know maybe give get some treatment
and and then keep it moving but it's a
medical problem it's a personal problem
unless you put somebody else in harm's
way you know if you get behind the wheel
of an airplane or you're behind
in a cockpit of airplane you're flying
around high as a kite that's not okay
right it's not okay to drive a tractor
either but you know
if you're if you're doing it in your
house
it's none of our freaking business and
i got an idea i talk about this on my
podcast a lot of wrongful conviction
right like what can you do well first of
all you know what you can do
if you're sitting here listening and
getting angry as i am again
um you can go serve on juries right when
you get the jury duty notice that you're
going to get some time
don't throw it away don't come up with
an excuse
and i'm not going to say i've never done
that because that would be hypocritical
but i feel badly for having done it i
won't do it again i'll tell you that
much i did it a long time ago
um you know and i had a legitimate
excuse but in theory in in
you know in retrospect i sh you know i
would have preferred to have gone
um but that being said you know you're
allowed a certain number of deferments
whatever it is but the fact is that
don't do that go and serve on a jury
and you can exercise your uh um
you know your rights as a juror you know
you can be you can do
what's that called civil disobedience or
be conscious object or whatever the hell
the
proper name for it is but you can just
vote not to convict
if you see an injustice like that you
see a stephen lennon or something like
that and you go this is out of whack
like i'm not i i you know i can't
support a system that doesn't make sense
even you might think
you know i mean i was called on a case
once and they rejected me as a juror
because who's going to take me as a
juror anyway i wish they would
if they look up my back after that last
statement that they could just play this
recording and being like
this guy for sure but the fact is that
i remember being in the courtroom this
huge ornate courtroom in new york city
and
and there was a hundred jurors waiting
to be called and a judge looked like a
very regal in his robes it was a guy who
was accused of
selling i think a tenth of a gram of
cocaine
in a school zone right which by the way
all of manhattan is a school zone
there's no place you can go that's not a
thousand feet from some sort of school
it could be a ballet school it could be
a secretarial school it could be
anything
they still count it and they count it
through the building too like i'll
remember that
that discussion right like you know
there was a case
not this case there was a case where the
lawyer said well you have to go this way
and this way around the corner they said
no no you go through the building
diagonally and you so less than a
thousand feet
but this guy was accused it was a tenth
of a gram
a tenth of a gram it's hard to think of
anything that weighs a tenth of a gram
like a pin
a little pin ladies probably ways about
that it's it's it's so tiny it's almost
you know it's almost anyway whatever so
that being said
um it's it's an incredible waste of
taxpayer resources but i do think
it goes back to the wrongful conviction
stuff too um
you know when i started that podcast
my goal was to help create a more
educated jury pool
so that people don't go in there and
just believe whatever they're being told
because a lot of bad stuff goes on in
our system there are reverse incentives
you talked about over the private
prisons
there are reverse incentives throughout
our system right there
look even if everybody in the system was
was well-meaning
and was you know had slept well the
night before and wasn't
you know you know basically wasn't human
right but everybody operated the way
they should
there would still be mistakes but the
problem is it's not like that right the
the system is an adversarial system
prosecutors are trying to get
convictions
defense lawyers are trying to get their
clients out but it's a mismatch
all throughout and it starts being a
mismatch the minute you get arrested
like you said
now let's say you're in jail like
charnel mitchell but
and maybe that's not the best example
because she wasn't even charged with a
crime but let's say you're charged with
a crime
and you're looking at sitting in jail
for a year waiting trial
or pleading guilty and you're probably
gonna plead guilty then you're gonna
have a record forever then you're gonna
get
busted on probation you know violations
which could be the most benign things
right they call them technical parole
violations
forgetting to report a change of address
going to
you know you'd be crossing a state line
to pick up your son or daughter
and that could be a violation you could
there's a million other you can eat a
poppy seed bagel and fail a drug test
that's a thing by the way
that's a real thing um any of these
things you can miss an appointment with
your parole officer right back to jail
so um the the whole thing
is designed to fail and
again you know if you think about here's
here's
here's another aspect i think is
underreported you may not even know this
andrew and you know a lot
but one of the craziest things when
you're trying
somebody in court and they're in jail
awaiting trial
they get picked up at the jail around
three in the morning and brought to a
holding cell
in the courthouse typically where they
wait hours and hours they don't get fed
because they miss the breakfast in
prison and then
they're sitting there for hours until
they come to court they don't get
dropped off again until around midnight
that night
back in their cell so if they can sleep
after this traumatic process
they're sleeping maybe three hours now
you're coming to court you haven't had a
haircut because you're in [ __ ] prison
you're in jail
you know you you're a mess right and
you're there you're trying to fight for
your life with a public defender who's
probably working on hundreds of other
cases
who may not even know your name and
you know and the other problem which is
something you can do something about is
that
studies have shown that around 80
percent of people have a preconceived
notion that whoever's in the defendant's
chair must have done something wrong or
they wouldn't be there
so all of the odds are stacked against
the defendant and if i can do
something through this podcast and
through you know my work
and being on your show which you know
thanks again for having me
to help tip those odds back towards
fairness
then you know that's you know that's
that's my
calling as i'm here for there is a very
human
tendency to think well uh this person
must have done something wrong like
because you just don't want to believe
that the system is so blatantly
unjust uh though now we have so much
evidence that system is blatantly unjust
a certain percentage of the time and
that percentage is better than any of us
would like it to be
uh and that if you're on the wrong end
of this then you just get your life
destroyed and because everyone has this
preconception well you must have done
something wrong it's like
you know like there's at this point we
have to wake up to the fact that
if there's something going wrong it's
that we've let the system go berserk
we've let the system go berserk that's
just
tripping on people right and left and
unfortunately it's trending most often
among uh
on people that have the least ability to
uh counteract it to deploy resources so
that they can
uh actually fight it out in a legitimate
way
uh it's one reason why what you do is so
important is you're taking people that
don't have those resources and you're
helping them
you're helping amplify their stories
you're helping them with legal
uh advice and and uh folks that are
actually going to get into the guts of
these cases and say look
you know there's no reason why this
person needs to be behind bars or this
person was treated unfairly
[Music]
i'm literally wearing adrenaline
clothing right now uh because they sent
them to me
and then i loved them and so now we uh
have them as a sponsor the podcast and
then i did something where i just like
went on the site and
bought it some more and then they sent
it to me too you know what i did i
actually used my own discount code isn't
that fun i
entered my code yang at checkout to get
25
off my full price order that's outer
known.com
o u t e r k n o w n
dot com use code yang at checkout for 25
off so why do i like these clothes
they're
made well they're made sustainably so
you know that uh
you know you're not hurting the
environment any more than you'd have to
uh they were founded by pro surfer and
11 time world champion
surfer kelly slater so it's got that
vibe you know what i mean it's got that
kind of
comfortable i'm a cool guy
like uh i could be on a beach it's kind
of got that vibe
though it's not really a beach because
like one of the shirts that i wear all
the time is called a blanket shirt
uh and it is so heavy that it is like
wearing a blanket
where oftentimes i'll just go outside
and not
bother with like a hoodie or whatnot
because the blanket shirt is like
wearing a blanket
so if that kind of stuff sounds good to
you check out outernown.com
use my code yang at checkout for 25 off
so we are at a cultural moment when it
feels like
the world has come your way jason uh you
know you started
started this work 27 years ago and now
here we are 27 years later saying
we need to make changes what are you
excited about first would you agree that
this is the highest
level of energy and momentum you've seen
for meaningful
reformation of drug laws and reformation
of the criminal justice system
and what do those changes look like if
it's true
that at this point people on both sides
of the aisle agree that we need to to
make real changes
yeah i mean there are definitely people
on both sides i mean you know the
i'm working with uh you know it's it
sounds like
a crazy uh uh combination but
i'm working with the stand together
foundation which is a
foundation that um was started by chase
coke
um you know who you know then they are
libertarian that family right and so
um there are certainly a lot of issues
we don't see eye to eye on but on
criminal justice reform they are
they're they're on it i mean they are
not playing games and they
they see things i think largely through
the same lens that we
do and they're very effective because um
they just have terrific people working
there and they
are you know they're they're
they're gonna be change makers but i
think there are there are so many
incredible people
um in this fight now um you know i
mentioned alakar kazanis i mentioned
some of the organizations that i'm
i'm working with um you know fam.org
fantasy expansion minimums the drug
policy alliance the legal action center
in new york is a fantastic organization
mother's board i also serve
um there are um you know
there there there's movement in a number
of areas i think that the
um abolition of cash bail is
is a you know it's a slow
process it has to go city by city county
by county state by state
but it's happening um the you know
they're only two they're too uh it's
crazy you know there are only two
countries in the world that have money
uh
for-profit bail bonds uh uh systems did
you know that
and the other one who i give you a bonus
prize yeah
if you can figure it out the philippines
is the only other one um
and that's brought it to them we
probably like hey there's a great idea
yeah we exported it yeah but
but you touched on this before andrew
the decriminalization of pot
is you know it's interesting when i
started working on that stuff
in 93 somebody very wise told me you
know it takes 30 years to change
anything in washington and i was like
well
if that's the case we're ahead of
schedule but so
uh so the decriminalization and the
destigmatization of
pot i think is is a very very exciting
development and
kudos to governor polis and governor
um who else just did this was it uh it
was inslee right
who just um granted clemency um
is in colorado there was another state
out west where
they just granted you know sort of
thousands of clemencies
to low level love it look at that
they're taking a page out of like the
the yang campaign promises book not even
clemency pardons
yeah any governors around the country
does freaking follow the lead
everyone will love you pardon the folks
who are in jail for non-violent drug
related offenses
uh and you'll be a hero yeah also the
ones who are
out you know like they need to be
pardoned as well because their records
need to be explained too ridiculous
right
exactly then andrew will meet them
outside with a bit with a uh you know
with a high five and
for whatever you did the governor let
the governor be there and do the high
fives
you know even in new york city we have
you know we have our share of problems
here but the
you know the number of drug arrests has
declined uh
drastically which i'm encouraged by um i
think that the
you know the innocence project has been
behind uh
a tremendous number of reforms of uh
of practices and and even some um
you know passing legislation as of other
organizations like the anti-recidivism
coalition
and others who are instituting fairer
and better practices there's a movement
away from these draconian sentences
i mean what you know it was not that
long ago that the miller decision and
the supreme court that brian stevenson
won
abolished a mandatory life in prison
for you know kids who were as young as
like 12
for non-homicide offenses i mean no
other country does that nobody
my friend ian manuel who was sentenced
to life without parole when he was 13
for non-violent friend sorry not in that
violent for non-homicide defense he was
not innocent
but he was 13. and you know he ended up
serving
18 years in solitary confinement 26
years total i mean it's insane
no he's but he's a terrific guy he's
doing really well now he's got a book
coming out i'm very very proud of him
brian stevenson
you know won his case brian is a great
hero of mine so
you know but the there is um
there is movement towards
you know eliminating these insane
sentences i think the death penalty i'm
encouraged by that as well i mean
i i hate the death penalty um everyone
should hate the death penalty in my view
um
you know i've seen too many cases where
even the victim's family went and begged
for the
for the the killer of their loved one
not to be
executed didn't matter you know we're so
bloodthirsty in this country
and you know it was in missouri that the
i don't remember who it was it might
have been the attorney general
who said yeah you know evidence of
innocence should not uh
be a factor it doesn't you know i mean
i'm i'm paraphrasing and i don't want to
name names or anything but
the fact is that those kind of phrases
get uttered in courtrooms in america
i mean it's like and you know i think it
was wasn't it scalia who said something
like that though it was like uh
um that the um they basically the basic
idea was that the
evidence of innocence shouldn't stand in
the way of procedures right you must
adhere to procedures
um and it has to be that's more
important
there are a lot of people in america
that just take
solace behind uh
just like the rule and application of
the rules like well that's the rule
you know and and it's like come on you
like you know that uh
playing this rule uh is not the right
thing and it was like all those are
rules
there's like a very very strong rules
our rules
contingent in in america and that's one
of the problems here is that we put
these rules on the books that have
enabled all of these
uh abuses uh and uh
and there's no coming back from the
death penalty you know i mean at this
point we have to look up and say
well geez we've found people that were
wrongfully convicted on death row
some people are wrongfully con you know
i mean imagine you get there too late
well it's like
there's no reversing that one oh and i'm
gonna throw something at you right now
which i think will shock a lot of people
which is that
there's my my uh my friend josh dubin
who was the host of the junk science
podcast which is part of our
our network um we can find it under the
wrongful conviction feed but
he um he's representing a guy in florida
named
james daly uh james daley has been on
death row for about 35 years in florida
the state
of florida tried to execute him last
year but there was a stay
court granted a state but james daly is
obviously innocent
it is such a the new york times did a
cover story about this case because of
the
jailhouse snitch who was involved this
was one of the most notorious jailhouse
niches in the history of america he
apparently 37 different people felt
compelled to confess their crimes to him
even though he was a known snitch in
jail
right he just happened to be walking by
mr daily cell with the
jail daley just felt like spilling his
guts to this guy
so we've never met in his life and they
weren't even the same part of the prison
or jail but here's the thing about the
james daley case
he's a military veteran he had nothing
to do with this crime
everybody knows it the real killer has
confessed in affidavits in every which
way
and yet the state of florida is
desperate to execute him
and here's the craziest thing
if florida executes mr daly he will be
the hundredth person put to death
put to death by the state of florida now
how many people do you think have been
exonerated from florida's death row
29 let me make it easy for you 29 people
have been exonerated from death row now
it is so damn difficult to get
exonerated from anywhere but from death
row it's even harder
so even if we accept the ridiculously
well the the the false premise that
florida that everyone that florida has
executed was guilty and we know that's
not true
because of jesse tefero and because of
others i'm just coming up with names
right now i'm struggling but
there are other names i can think of in
florida of people who were innocent who
were executed on death row jesse tafaro
was definitely one of them
but even if all those people were guilty
they're not even batting 700
and yet we continue to tinker with the
machinery of death
what are we doing how how can you have a
system like that
if that's what brian stephenson says if
one out of every 10 planes crashed
nobody would fly in florida it's three
out of ten
and yet they're so desperate to execute
james daly
and and by the way here's another thing
florida would save
if they if they commuted everybody on
florida's death row to life in prison
they would save 51 million dollars a
year in taxpayer money
just by doing that the death penalty is
expensive it's arbitrary
it's capricious it's racist and it is
a fact that we execute innocent people
in this country
and it's nev that's never going to
change it might go up or down by degrees
but it's never going to change
as long as we have the death penalty
we'll continue to do that that's another
thing this country has to get better at
jason is just to say look we screwed up
you know what i mean like i
i you get a sense that that's one of the
reasons why they don't want to exonerate
james daley or other people is they
don't want to be like well turns out
this person's been in jail for a while
and
like we [ __ ] that one up you know it's
like like
that there's like a real unwillingness
half the time it wasn't even you
half the time it was like some other
freaking like you know attorney or like
whoever the heck it was like district
attorney it's like
not even your screw-up and they still
just don't want to be
they don't just want to be like our bad
our bad
there just needs to be a lot more
responsibility taking on that side i
think that would that would improve our
lives
so much of people different positions of
power just admitted to screwing up
and then we're like yeah that's our bad
like this person should not be in jail
this person should not be on death row
like you don't get that much
in american life uh like that there is
like
more likely for people to want to
continue
uh the screw up and just be like yeah
it's
you know like like move on move on
nothing to see here this was well done
then to just be like yeah that was our
fault
it's even worse than that because they
um
in many you know i don't know to say the
majority but in many many cases they
will protect
wrongful convictions even though they
know they're wrong even though they've
been proven wrong even though a higher
court has overturned the conviction
and in many cases they'll try to get
those people to take an alfred play
or some other plea just so they can
maintain their perfect record or
whatever the hell they have
even though they know that they were
wrong they might have known they were
wrong in the first place but now they've
been proven wrong
but they'll still fight and there's
reasons for that right there's no
prosecutorial accountability
they don't face any consequences for the
for their misdeeds or they're
or even breaking the law so and in fact
again there's another reverse incentive
which is that they
um you know they climb the ladder
typically by having
very you know high rates of convictions
and so they want to get somebody and
you know if you're it then so be it then
they go home and eat spaghetti with
their kids and you know
talk about the you know the day and then
keep it moving and
it's um you know it's it's it's
it's just all freaking wrong i mean
there's that and then there's another
issue which i get asked about all the
time which i think is important for
people to know
is that if you're wrongfully convicted
and you serve
four years or 15 years or 40 years or
27 years like so many people that i've
interviewed on my show
have done there's no guarantee of
compensation there are only there are 18
states that have no compensation
statutes and the innocence project is
leading the charge to fix that
um and we're fixing it state by state
but even among the states that do have
it in some of the places it's
woefully low i genuinely didn't know
that there was compensation even
possible in
in some of the states uh it doesn't
surprise me that there's no compensation
in a lot of places
um it actually surprised me that they
actually hope
you've been in jail for 10 years are bad
i mean is the least people
deserve i mean what the hell would
someone accept for 10 years of their
freedom you'd have to
get into like exorbitant sums for anyone
to even like you know imagine it and
there's nothing you can do to give
someone their
life back their youth back those years
back no
the trauma the whole thing no one other
thing i i want to try to squeeze in here
is that i think it's so important that
people
learn about the quote-unquote sciences
in the courtroom that's why we started
this show called junk science
wrongful conviction junk science i know
i sound like a broken record but i'm
really proud of this show
because in it each week we examine
a different forensic discipline that so
many people have been bamboozled by
shows like csi to believe are
you know gospel we cover everything from
arson right
these arson investigators who who
basically
known absolutely nothing you could be a
trained arson investigator with a
40-hour correspondence course
basically right and the same is true for
some other for the
blood spatter same thing you want to be
a blood spatter analyst 40 hours don't
take my advice don't do it
by the way um but the fact is that you
know
you you have to train what is it six
months to become a barber or a
manicurist i mean
and yet these people are in court
testifying they don't know anything
but it goes further than that you know
there's there's um
there's uh um there's boot print
analysis
but even fingerprints even fingerprints
which we all think about fingerprints
right
fingerprint analysis is almost totally
subjective we like not to believe that
but it's true and don't get me started
on shaking baby syndrome if you end up
on a jury on a shaken baby syndrome case
you really have to be a skeptic jon
jones melissa kaliazinski there's so
many people i know that are in prison in
america for for
supposedly shaking a baby to death
because again it goes back to their
psychology we don't want to believe that
babies could just die
but sometimes it happens but you know
that
we won't talk about that for a second
but the fingerprints right remember the
case in madrid
all those years ago when it wasn't that
long ago actually i think it was less
than a decade ago
although all the bombings on the trains
in madrid and
it was in the 2000s for sure but or 2010
191 people were killed one morning in
madrid
terrible series of bombings on commuter
trains and buses
and you know pure pandemonium said and
of course and they
you know they got fingerprints off of
one of the devices
and they put it in the worldwide you
know database or whatever the hell and
they went to
the different you know interpol all
these different organizations got about
we covered this on the show
i've covered it much better i'm gonna
give you the capsule summary
and ultimately the fbi found a match
of a guy i think he was a lawyer he
lived in oregon
and um they uh
arrested him charged him with these
bombings
turns out he had never been to spain
now they've never been dismayed he'd
have a passport but the fbi insisted
that he did it
they had three or four different
analysts that looked at the fingerprint
said it was an
absolute definite match certainly a
hundred percent
no doubt about it that's the guy that
did it blah blah blah and finally the
spanish authorities were like
you people need to get your [ __ ]
together
this ain't the guy he's never been to
spain
we don't know what you're talking about
these are not his fingerprints
it's but but you know in a case that
high profile with multiple senior
experts like that now think about it
then you're in a small town somewhere
right
and you have the local you know one of
the local
officers or or people in the work in the
department somewhere who's assigned to
be a fingerprint
you know analyst fingerprints you know
it's if you do a fingerprint on an ink
pad and another one on an ink pad
maybe you could take a microscope and
you could look at it you could go you
know those that's pretty close match
but if i if i'm on your your neck or
something right and it's
you're sweating or i'm sweating or the
skin
or you have skin in your hard skin or
soft skin or you're muscular or you're
or you're chubby or you're this or that
it's all smudgy and weird it doesn't
make a full perfect fingerprint
like we would like to think it does
that's not the way it
works and therefore that evidence is
bogus as [ __ ] and yet it's used
and the thing about courtrooms is this
is so nuts right i'm glad
i finally got to this so the thing about
court was is that our legal system is
almost the opposite of science
because the in in our courts
they will admit evidence that science
has proven as false
because it's been admitted before right
so bite mark evidence like bite mark
evidence is ridiculous if you're ever in
a case with bite mark evidence if
there's a lot of other evidence okay
maybe you look at it
but if that's what they got throw that
[ __ ] out the window that bite mark
evidence is a joke
and yet it's allowed in courtrooms in
all 50 states just because it's always
been allowed in courtrooms in all 50
states
so they just go well some other judge in
1968
allowed it so i guess we're going to
allow it too and
it's ridiculous yeah biting on an
imperfect surface
you know that the studies have shown
they did studies with the top hundred
forensic odontologists
in the country and in many cases they
couldn't even tell they thought it was a
human bite mark it turned out it was an
animal
or it was it was you know they have no
idea because ontology is
is basically your full set of teeth it
was created as a protocol
so that if there's a plane crash or
something and your
body is in smithereens they can take
your whole set of teeth and go to your
dentist's office and
voila they know it's you and okay fine
or the building collapses
but then you take that versus somebody
biting down on an
imperfect surface or a couple of teeth
and then yet you have some quack idiot
who goes on the thing and says i'm
certified in forensic old ontology and i
can guarantee you this is andrew's teeth
on this dead body here which was found
in a swamp
you know 17 days late it's ridiculous
but it passes as science
and we need to change that too you know
it's that old saying i think it was an
english tourist or somebody who said
it's better that
a hundred guilty men go free than the
one instance should suffer
we may disagree on the percentages but
we can we can do something about it but
we need everybody to do it so listen to
the damn show
get educated and serve on jury if you
get picked up and charged with crime or
even you get picked up and brought in
for
for a a an interview and they want you
to
andrew we just want to talk to you about
this crime you don't know anything about
it but we think you might be able to
help and most people want to help
i grew up you know respecting the the
uniform i wanted to be a
cop when i was a kid i still respect the
uniform but
you know good cops of course i respect
them
but the thing about it is don't say a
word
except for my name is andrew and i want
a lawyer
you can say your full name if you want
to that's not a problem but and i want a
lawyer and then stop talking until your
lawyer gets
they will be used against you and
they're allowed to lie in the
interrogation
very important for you to know that they
can tell you listen andrew you seem like
a nice guy but we got your fingerprints
on the murder weapon
we got a guy across the hall who says
you did it you know there's nobody
across the hall
we have a video of you leaving the
apartment building right after the
murder and you're sitting there going
what
but they're allowed to lie so yeah don't
say a word
so if someone wants to help aside from
plugging into the resources that you're
providing like
is there a particular organization uh or
a place that should go
particular way that an activist uh can
move the needle on something yeah i
would encourage people to go to
innocenceproject.org uh go to famm.org
drugpolicyalliance.org
if you want to donate to help people uh
coming home
from prison uh innocent people uh or
people who've served these ridiculous
sentences for minor crimes etc
uh there's a great organization called
the first 72 plus
that's the first seven number 72 and
then plus dot org
um can you do the plus on the dot org i
think so but anyway if you google for 70
plus it'll come up
um and by the way uh please follow me on
instagram it's at it's jason flom it's
jason flom i'm posting about these
things all the time and you can learn
more that way
um and of course uh download the the
podcast
but uh yeah and there and then you know
you know
just learn and and and show up and get
involved and vote
vote vote vote vote in not only a
presidential race but vote in your local
elections
learn about the judges who are running
learn about the prosecutors who are
running learn about the
assembly people anybody throughout the
system
because your your vote matters there's
been that it was a couple years ago
there was a race in virginia that ended
up in a dead heat a tie
the same exact number people voted on
both sides so don't give me that my vote
doesn't matter [ __ ] because it's not
true
vote in your local elections vote in
people who are going to do the right
thing because they're out there
but they need your support thank you
jason
thank you for fighting for humanity for
so long uh
in a way that was not
prominent or visible but now it's
getting the prominence
it deserves in american thought american
life hopefully we can change some of
these systems and rules
so that they start working better for us
and that we can actually start feeling
like our justice system is a justice
system as opposed to
a system that right now uh is serving
serving multiple ends that unfortunately
have very little to do with justice but
appreciate the god of your
dedication over these years and for
you're helping free people that should
not have been in jail
in the first place and bringing those
cases to light you're you're like uh
now uh
you're the equivalent of a saint to many
of these people that you have helped
free it's one reason why they're so
indebted to you
um and we're all indebted to you so
thank you and let's hope that your
vision
for how we can reform the system becomes
a reality as soon as possible
well i appreciate your giving me this
this platform to speak to your audience
and i appreciate all these things that
you've been doing and i'm looking
forward to working closely with you
uh to make this uh country fairer and
better for everyone
you and me both jason really hats off to
you so incredible
uh working down and so glad to be
connected with you thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]